is it possible to have too much
responsibility to take too much
responsibility for yourself like
one thing i've been thinking is that
the victim mindset where you want to
you believe that you have no control
over the outcomes in your life
i wonder whether there's an opposite
where you believe that you have an
infinite amount of control over them and
you lose faith in your innate ability to
just carry you through
i've been thinking a lot about releasing
the tiller which is a jed mckenna quote
he's talking about the fact that the
best way to
ride a boat
through a storm is to actually release
the tiller and it allows the boat to
maneuver best through the swells and i
think that a lot of the time going back
to the imposter syndrome thing that we
were talking about as you start to
accumulate more and more competence
the
higher level of overthinking the higher
level of neuroticism the more of an
attention to detail that got you from
naught to 50 isn't necessarily the thing
that's going to get you from 50 to 100
you know you had to get across a river
and it was it was bad and difficult you
don't need to carry that boat across
ground to then get you across the next
one and i wonder whether
the opposite of a victim mentality where
you take responsibility for the things
that occur in life i wonder whether you
can overshoot you can for sure yeah
definitely
i mean
you know dostoevsky said that every man
was responsible for everything he did
and for everything that everyone else
does which is kind of an insane
statement but also
somewhat it's true in in in a certain
sense
you do have an indefinite responsibility
and you do have an indefinite capacity
to bear that responsibility but that
doesn't mean it can't be crushing and
then i would say the antidote to that is
that you're not in this alone
as your responsibilities mount
and your opportunities
increase
you have to delegate
more and more there's enough for every
there's an it's important that you do
everything you can but there's enough
for everyone to do
and so you might say well
the heroic path is one that leads to
universal redemption and that's true and
you might say well that's all on you
it's like it is in a sense but then
the problem that you just described
comes children too much burden well it
can crush you
it can be unsustainable right you can
torture yourself for not doing it well
enough
and it is up to you but it's not up to
you alone
it's not up to you alone
so you delegate you and you you build
you help build people around you
so that they're all working in the same
direction it's an effort it's an effort
multiplier in any case and you make sure
that they get credit they and i they get
they get
credit isn't exact credit's good enough
it's it's not exactly right
the rewards are
are in accordance with their efforts and
you can distribute that you know because
there's also a narcissism that can come
along with that which is well it's all
up to me
and even if you're working in a very
competent manner it can seem that way
but
there's plenty of work to go around and
there's plenty of credit where credit is
due and so what you do as you attain
more responsibility and opportunity is
you delegate more of that and you do
that continually i mean one of the roles
of a good manager is to make him or
herself irrelevant absolutely yeah right
so if you're not a good manager if your
company would collapse if you
disappeared
that should all be delegated out and
it's not because you're abdicating
responsibility because also what happens
is that if you can routinely someone
something and parse it off to someone
else say here's a little kingdom for you
and it doesn't have to be little and
it's something that can grow but here's
the kingdom for you
well then you can go off and do the next
thing you need to do which is extremely
important you know and you might think
there's there's a kingdom and then it's
broken into little kingdoms and so the
farther you are down the hierarchy the
smaller the kingdom you get but that's
only true if you think the world's a
zero-sum game
because you could also think of it as a
place of indefinite
a place with an indefinite number of the
largest kingdoms possible
and i think what why do we think this is
exhaustible in some sense what we're
doing it doesn't look exhaustible
you know that's the limits to growth
mentality it's like
economists don't believe in that
because they think well no we can just
get more efficient which we certainly
are we're way more efficient than we
once were
and those gains in efficiency when
they're not being interfered with are
increasing at
more than an arithmetic rate why do you
think people have a tendency toward that
zero-sum mentality
when i find myself thinking that it's
one of the first things that i check
myself on that is
that is cancer
yeah well i mean there are elements of
life that have a zero-sum element i mean
if you're competing with another man for
example to marry a particular woman
that's
a zero-sum game if you only think of the
game as including you two and that woman
so you can set up circumstances that are
zero-sum
but then port them across into
situations which aren't yeah well then
but to take take that metaphor of
zero-sum game where there has to be
winners and losers because there's a
finite number of resources is to assume
that the rules of that game are the
rules that govern all game the set of
all games and that's just not true
there's games are infinitely
multipliable i mean you can invent a new
game people do that all the time the man
who invented catan which is a game i
really like to play
it's very popular board game that didn't
exist until he invented it now you know
thousands and thousands of people play
it and he made a fortune from it's like
that game never existed
so
there doesn't seem to be any limit to
the number of games we can invent
and
it's a complicated problem because
we are on a single planet and
and
some resources are more zero-sum than
others but we haven't really run into
any actual zero-sum limits in terms of
our
you know the probability of us living an
abundant life on the planet
we've we've stewarded some resources
very stupidly we've done a very bad job
of of managing
oceanic production for example
although
fish farms have alleviated that on the
production side to some degree but
it's a tragedy of the commons that we
could address and should address as far
as i'm concerned one of the good things
the trudeau government has done i think
to give the devil is due let's say is to
put a lot of the coast of
canada into marine protected areas and
that's smart we have to be smart about
our resources but that doesn't mean
there's zero sum and certainly doesn't
mean the world is a zero-sum game
and that's a malthusian idea you know
that population will grow till it
consumes all available resources and
precipitously collapse and then why do
we think apocalyptically it's well
because things do come to sudden ends
people die people get fatal illnesses
like the world you so carefully
constructed can be blown apart at any
moment by a random occurrence genetic
mutation that causes the cancer that
kills you like life has a like life has
a fundamentally apocalyptic aspect
and we do understand that because we're
self-conscious and then it's very
difficult not to apply that kind of
apocalyptic reasoning to
things as such
the world's going to burn up
the climate's too hot what about runaway
positive feedback loops because that's
what the climate types are afraid of
it's like hey they happen
how do we bind our apocalyptic thinking
that's a good question man
that's a good question we do that
through truth
we do that with the truth that's how we
do it through dialogue through
investigation through exploration
through discipline
all of that the logos is the antidote to
the apocalypse of course that's central
christian
dogma isn't that that the logos is the
apoc is the antidote to the apocalypse
[Music]
fancy that
and so what does that mean love and
truth is the antidote to the apocalypse
not the planet has too many people on it
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace